dejando el puesto remoto un alejandro
salió en un viaje de tres días al
desierto su desplazamiento distancia y
dirección del inicio al final del primer
día es de 1 el vector de uno que es
igual a tomar unos tres veces el vector
unitario y más siete veces el vector
unitario j su desplazamiento del inicio
al final del segundo día es decir de dos
el vector de dos que por cierto es lo
mismo que menos una vez el vector
unitario y más ocho veces el vector
unitario jota y aquí están su
desplazamiento del primer día fue justo
a este y su desplazamiento del segundo
día fue justo este su desplazamiento en
el tercer día el vector de subíndice 3
lo llevó de regreso al puesto remoto es
decir de subíndice 3 lo va a regresar al
punto de partida
ok las distancias anteriores están en
kilómetros cuál fue la distancia que
alejandro viajó en el tercer día
redondea a la décima más cercana en qué
dirección viajó alejandro en el tercer
día
al grado más cercano tu respuesta debe
estar entre 0 y 360 grados así que como
no podemos trabajar en la página del
navegador de internet entonces voy para
camps y voy a sacar aquí mi libreta de
apuntes ya está aquí tengo justo el
mismo problema y date cuenta que es lo
que nos preguntan es qué va a pasar con
este vector de subíndice 3 y bueno de
una vez quiero dibujarlo este vector de
subíndice 3 es un vector que va a
empezar aquí y que me va a regresar al
punto de partida es decir me va a
regresar justo aquí atrás la magnitud y
la dirección de este vector es atrás lo
que voy es decir este es mi vector que
me va a importar saber su magnitud y su
dirección así que déjenme poner que este
es el vector de de subíndice 3 ok
este es el vector del cual quiero saber
su magnitud y su dirección y bueno para
resolver este problema lo que quiero que
te des cuenta es que este vector está
muy relacionado con el vector de
subíndice 1 y con el vector
2 de hecho este vector se parece mucho a
la suma del vector de subíndice 1 y del
vector de subíndice 2 la única
diferencia es que va en dirección
contraria en sentido contrario si nos
fijamos en la suma de t subíndice 1 y de
subíndice 2
bueno pues será un vector que se vería
más o menos así
sería un vector que se tendría la misma
magnitud algo exactamente igual ok pero
que apuntaría hacia el lado contrario
apuntaría para acá entonces si te das
cuenta este subíndice 3 es menos la suma
de estos dos y lo voy a poner signo
negativo para que vaya en sentido
contrario eso es muy importante si yo
tengo un vector aquí le voy a poner mi
vector am ok
mi vector menos am va a tener la misma
magnitud que el vector a solamente que
va a apuntar en sentido contrario éste
sería menos mi vector
y de lujo por lo tanto este vector de
tres y para no confundirnos mejor déjame
quitar todo esto que tengo aquí a mi
vector de 3 va a ser menos la suma de
estos dos y déjame ponerlo así el vector
de 3 es exactamente lo mismo vector de 3
que la suma de estos dos ok pero con
signo contrario así que déjame ponerlo
aquí es observación es muy importante
este vector de 3 es exactamente lo mismo
que el vector de 1 ok a esto le voy a
sumar el vector de 2 vamos a sumarle el
vector de 2 el vector de 2 y cuando yo
me tomo la suma va en sentido contrario
así que para que esto tenga la dirección
que yo quiero me voy a tomar esta suma
pero negativa me voy a tomar esta suma
pero negativa de lujo ahora lo bueno de
esto es que tenemos expresado al
director de uno en sus componentes
rectangulares y también al vector de 2
por lo tanto podemos tomarnos esta suma
de una manera muy fácil así que déjame
escribirlo aquí esto va a ser
exactamente igual
12 - 1 que multiplica al vector de uno
pero el vector de uno lo podemos
descomponer en esta que es mi componente
horizontal es decir tres veces el vector
unitario y ok ya esto le sumamos lo voy
a poner con este color
le voy a sumar siete veces el vector
unitario jota más siete veces el vector
unitario jota esto es lo mismo que el
vector de uno y por otra parte el vector
de dos está representado por estos dos
componentes van por una componente
horizontal que es esta menos una vez el
vector unitario y menos el vector
unitario y ok ya esto am le voy a sumar
ocho veces el vector unitario j
a esto le voy a sumar ocho veces el
vector unitario jota y de lujo así nos
podemos tomar la suma estos dos vectores
de una manera muy sencilla así que
déjame cerrar aquí este paréntesis y
bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que
menos a abramos paréntesis otra vez
tres veces el vector unitario y menos
una vez el rector un interior y bueno
pues son dos veces el vector unitario y
ok de lujo y por otra parte tengo siete
veces el vector unitario jota más ocho
veces el vector auditorio j
eso es lo mismo que 15 8 + 7 es 15 15
veces el vector unitario jota de lujo y
ahora sí ya tengo de una manera muy
fácil de una manera representada en sus
dos componentes a este vector de tres
este vector de tres déjame ponerlo así
es exactamente lo mismo que menos dos
veces menos dos veces el vector unitario
y ok ya esto le voy a restar a 15 veces
el vector unitario jota y de lujo ya
tengo a este efector de tres visto como
la suma de la forma escalada de los
vectores rectangulares y por lo tanto ya
tenemos cuáles son los componentes
rectangulares de este vector de tres y
es más lo podemos ver justo aquí en este
vector de 3
para formarlo hay que caminar dos
unidades hacia la izquierda es decir
hasta acá
ok caminamos dos unidades y después hay
que bajar 15 unidades de manera vertical
ok y después hay que bajar am y déjame
cambiar de color después voy a bajar a
15 unidades hasta llegar aquí ok de lujo
estas son mis dos componentes
rectangulares de este vector ahora
quiero que te des cuenta que entonces
estamos formando un triángulo rectángulo
este triángulo rectángulo de aquí y por
lo tanto ya podemos saber cuál es la
magnitud de este vector de 3 y de lujo
ya podemos saber cuánto vale la magnitud
déjame ponerlo así la magnitud de este
vector de 3
ok tomándonos un teorema de pitágoras
muy sencillo esto es lo mismo que la
raíz cuadrada que la raíz cuadrada de el
cuadrado de cada una de las magnitud de
estas dos componentes es decir 2
su magnitud elevado al cuadrado me va a
quedar 4 ok ya esto le voy a sumar 15 15
elevado al cuadrado lo cuales 225 y
vamos a corroborarlo para eso voy a
tener acá a mi calculadora anda tengo
justo por acá y ahora voy a hacer
15 elevado al cuadrado de lujo 225 le
voy a sumar 4 y ahora a esto le voy a
sacar raíz cuadrada es 15.13 ahora si lo
redondeamos en la décima más cercana
esto es aproximadamente 15.1 así que
vamos a escribirlo esta está que es mi
magnitud de este vector de 3 es
aproximadamente aproximadamente y lo voy
a poner con este color 15.1 de lujo así
que aquí en esta respuesta va 15.1
kilómetros de luz ya tenemos la primera
respuesta que es la distancia que va a
viajar alejandro desde donde se quedó en
el día 2 hasta
el punto inicial es decir la magnitud de
este vector de 3 ahora lo que nos hace
falta es saber la dirección de este
vector de 3 y para eso voy a bajar un
poco la pantalla bajemos un poco la
pantalla la voy a bajar justo por la
cama para que nosotros podamos trabajar
con esta dirección y bueno para sacar
esta dirección ahora para sacar el
ángulo que te parece si hacemos un
pequeño esquema de lo que está pasando
justo aquí este vector de 3 está
apuntando hacia abajo se ve más o menos
así y es más déjame hacer su pequeña
flecha ok este es mi vector de 3000
vector de 3 ok y está apuntando hacia
abajo ok y lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que tenemos dos componentes
una componente la cual es la componente
horizontal es esta de aquí a la cual
ya sabemos que vale menos dos veces sí
ok
vamos a poner que esta es mi componente
horizontal y vale menos dos veces el
vector unitario y también tenemos una
componente vertical y esa componente
vertical la voy a poner
este color para que no nos afecte le voy
a poner con este color ok
y apunta hacia abajo ok y también
sabemos su magnitud su magnitud es menos
15 veces el vector unitario jota ok esto
es menos 15 veces el vector unitario
jota es decir esta parte de aquí esta
parte de aquí esta parte de aquí esta
parte de aquí de lujo ahora lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que este
vector de 3 el vector que nos va a
llevar de nuevo al punto inicial está
apuntando hacia abajo es decir que si
aquí tenemos a un plano que ya no puede
dibujar aquí un eje lo que me interesa
ver es este ángulo de aquí hasta acá
porque es un vector que está apuntando
hacia abajo sin embargo si nosotros
utilizamos el conocimiento de las
funciones trigonométricas el
conocimiento de las funciones
trigonométricas nos va a trabajar con
este triángulo rectángulo y por lo tanto
nos va a sacar solamente este ángulo de
aquí este ángulo de aquí no nos va a
sacar todo
este ángulo completo sin embargo no está
tan difícil encontrar todo este ángulo
completo porque todo este ángulo
completo es lo mismo que 180 grados
antes de ponerlo con este color de aquí
y hasta acá hay 180 grados ok
180 grados más este pequeño ángulo de
color amarillo que tenemos aquí más este
ángulo que tenemos aquí así que si
nosotros calculamos este ángulo que
tenemos aquí y le sumamos 180 grados
entonces ya tenemos el ángulo completo
desde aquí hasta acá que apunta hacia
abajo que nos dan una dirección de este
vector de 3 que apunta hacia abajo así
que para eso vamos a trabajar con este
triángulo que tenemos aquí para calcular
este ángulo que le voy a poner teta y
para calcular este ángulo que le voy a
poner theta vamos a fijarnos en este
triángulo este triángulo tiene como el
lado adyacente a este ángulo theta un
valor de 2 de 2 unidades como ángulo
opuesto a este ángulo theta un valor de
15 unidades y por lo tanto podemos
pensar en él
cuál es la función trigonométricas que
me junta al catetos yacente con el
cateto opuesto y bueno seguramente me
vas a decir que es la tangente así que
déjame escribirlo así la tangente la
tangente de este ángulo teta es
exactamente lo mismo que su lado opuesto
pero lo que vale el lado opuesto es 15
vamos a ponerlo con este color lo que
vale el lado opuesto es 15 que es la
magnitud de este vector entre a lo que
vale la magnitud de este otro vector de
este otro lado el lado adyacente que es
2 ok o dicho de otra manera como
nosotros queremos saber este ángulo
habrá que calcular a déjame ponerlo así
de aquí podemos obtener a déjame ponerlo
así que este ángulo es exactamente lo
mismo que la tangente inversa que la
tangente inversa de esta división que
tengo aquí de 15 entre 2 de 15
32 entre 2 o keith así que es hora de
sacar de nuevo la calculadora y ver
cuánto vale este ángulo theta que
tenemos aquí así que vamos a tenerla
aquí voy a hacer 15 lo voy a dividir
entre 2 ok ya esto le voy a sacar am con
la segunda función la tangente inversa
10 82.4 82.4 así que lo voy a poner aquí
te dan de eta es exactamente igual que
82.4 grados ok y si ahora a este ángulo
theta que solamente es esta parte de
aquí le sumamos 180 nos va a dar el
ángulo completo así que 82.4 grados más
180 bueno pues eso no es tan difícil
esto a mí déjame ponerlo con este color
blanco este ángulo que va desde aquí
hasta acá y es exactamente igual que me
dejaban ponerlo así 180 más 82 es 260
grados ok y bueno lo pongo sin punto
decimal porque dice redondea al grado
más cercano así que déjame ponerlo aquí
ya tenemos la respuesta esto es
exactamente igual que 262 grados así que
es hora de comprobar nuestra respuesta
voy a traer para acá nuestro navegador
de internet y ahora sí voy a poner la
respuesta activa 15.1 ok aquí abajo va
262 ok y comprobamos respuesta ahí de
lujo estamos bien